oh
look who it is andrew
andrew
what did you find
it is the day today we've all been
waiting for fried chicken fried chicken
fried chicken
all righty
all righty today okay we are in new york
city baby today on worth it we are going
to be trying three fried chicken spots
at three drastically different price
points to find out which fried chicken
is the most worth it at its price let's
go no hey we gotta talk about it
[Music]
my name is kenneth woods i'm president
and ceo of soviets i'm the son of
silvia's matter of fact it's a iconic
place this restaurant yeah back in the
60s everyone was leaving the south
coming to the city sylvia's home away
from home everyone felt comfortable the
stars the politicians the mom and pop a
few weeks ago we had three birthdays
ladies that was all over 90 years old
and three different parties it's the
great equalizer we do it traditional
southern style just like how my
grandmother used to make her chicken is
that where the recipe comes from it's a
food we use a three and a half pound
chicken trim it good then season it even
don't just season and throw it in the
fryer massage it like when you clean a
baby put the baby all on them that's how
you do the chicken treat your baby with
love that's right
fried chicken with love let it marinate
then drench it in all-purpose flour had
it to knock off the excess fry for 12
minutes and enjoy what you're doing yeah
it's amazing to be the oldest the
authentic the original all of those
little phrases you know mean something
all right well i think it's time to try
the fried chicken fried fricking chicken
one of the best meats and with one of
the best preparations welcome to
flavortown
[Music]
man oh there's like an extra crunchy
little bit right here the skin is a
perfect shell it's like a suit of armor
for a chicken tonight
you ready i am ready oh my gosh it's so
dreamy on the back to fried chicken
[Music]
oh i'm lost oh wait no i'm in fried
chicken heaven
[Music]
that is like music to my ears it's so
juicy inside it's just melting like
butter it's a food that takes a bath
when it gets cooked it has to be good
i'm shocked at how simple the
preparation actually is to get this
product that's when you know you've
mastered a crack when you can make it
look easy really is seasoned down to the
bone maybe the saddest sound at a fried
chicken dinner
that was less dramatic than i thought it
would be dramatic or dramatic you just
make a pun dramatic or dramatic
i think steven just made a really good
pun yeah that was on purpose
let's try some of the collard greens
[Music]
that is the perfect thing to eat
alongside of this
pretty [ __ ] good right
chocolate sylvias which is right there
we're going to red rooster which is over
there but uh we need to walk off some of
this fried chicken so
take a lap around the block what do you
think about soviets crispy simple juicy
can't ask for more than that so now
we're going to
hear that that's the sound of fried
chicken facts according to the national
chicken council the average american
eats over 90 pounds of chicken each year
i guess that makes sense it's gross when
you think about it just picturing a 90
pound chicken
that looks like a rottweiler oh i guess
that's like probably what a small
dinosaur would look like your time
feeling okay it's ready for more it's
always ready for more all right you just
try to hold my hand what no you're
standing very close to me okay fried
chicken
[Music]
welcome everybody my name is chef marcus
samson right now you're a red rooster
when i thought about red rooster it was
about how do i tackle fried chicken
being neighbor with the most iconic
restaurant in harlem of all time
sylvia's we can talk a lot about what we
have in common what does it mean to be a
restaurant in a community like harlem
for me it's all about hiring we have
about 180 employees 70 from harlem
people are so engaged i could never have
dreamt that the community takes so much
ownership of the restaurant it's a push
and pull when we make a mistake they let
us know we improve something they let us
know what is the name of the dish we're
having today fried yard bird yard burger
it was just like birds running around in
the back you know when you didn't have
food you could go out in the yard and
just cut a chicken and it's something
that both from my ethiopian and my
swedish heritage i want a seasoned oil
so i'm flavoring it with a little bit of
rosemary and garlic we have our bird a
little bit of pickling brine sugar salt
a little bit of buttermilk best thing is
that the bird can be there overnight and
then in our flour mix we have a shake
perfect the only ingredient that i will
let you know that's in that mix and what
is that burberry is a spice blend from
ethiopia large chilies are not super
spicy ginger garlic all sundry so it has
this beautiful terroir of ethiopia you
want the right amount of flour so you
get that crunchiness i landed on twice
fried chicken the first fry is really
all about cooking it through then you
lift it out let it rest then you just
dip it again and fry it so it gets
really nice and crunchy i have a little
bit of oil from that flavored oil that
we cooked in a little bit of hot honey
and our rooster sauce
all that stuff that i've used comes back
in really reflection of poor mass
cooking if you think about the food of
the south everyone that was working
class ate pretty much the same out of
that came a certain flavor point as the
migration moved the population up the
food state obviously tastes different in
new york or detroit than it does in
virginia or in kentucky the methods stay
just as much as jazz came up and today
we have hip-hop because of it the dna is
really the foods of the migration so we
got the yardbird you also got some
bourbon on the rocks because it's a hot
day in harlem
oh i'm ready now strangely very sweet
yeah he said there's a hot honey in that
hot honey is what they called me in high
school tell me who called you that no
one dibs on that one sure go for it
because this one's clearly about uh what
passed these
so good
oh my god oh i got it on my nose chicken
cheers
no
that is some juicy chicken
holy sh
that is a sophisticated flavor it's that
nice like deep roasted slightly bitter
nutty flavor that he was talking about
andrew with the adjectives adjective
andrew
oh
i can't believe how juicy this meat is
and the skin is perfect oh i just got
some skin in my bourbon the skin is
crispy and it melts in your mouth that's
like making love and i don't have any
experience in that department really i
don't but if i'm gonna be honest here
that's what i imagine it's like the
chicken and i have become one uh well
you know what i'm not going to spoil
anything for you i got it all over my
face right now
it's
so good it's crazy tonight can i jump in
please i really thought i was going to
get to eat that but well that's okay go
to the cornbread next to soak this up
yeah this is soap it's grimy man grimey
in a good way yeah right to the bird and
like that he's gone the structural
integrity of this skin with the coating
is unreal it's like soft and supple but
strong and mysterious adjective andrew
back at it again adjective andrew
sweet potato yams
the yams are like dessert mashed
potatoes so there's one piece of chicken
left can i have it
i asked marcus if you had any
suggestions for dessert oh it's so hot
turns out make my cake make some great
cake thank you
[Music]
that may have been it was the best fried
chicken i've ever had i said it first
we went to the quintessential harlem
fried chicken spot and now we're going
to
bat town oh i forgot about that how much
chicken do you think the united states
consumes every year a trillion chickens
a trillion chickens i'll recalculate a
little bit recalibrate
[Music]
two billion chickens not bad eight
billion chickens eight billion eight
billion so we ate a billion chickens i
was only a billion off no we ate eight
we eight billion we just went to
sylvia's the quintessential fried
chicken spot iconic red rooster game
changer now we're going downtown fried
chicken will be served at a noodle bar
and it's really hot in new york my brain
no good no more
hi i'm dave chang we've met before we're
at momofuku noodle bar in the east
village last time we saw you was in
korea i think you should try to eat the
chili pepper is it good yeah it's spicy
now we get to try your food does that
make you nervous i'm terrified
why because i'm competitive and if we
don't win not a guy probably the most
competitive person basically we're
serving fried chicken like picking duck
with caviar i understand how stupid and
almost douchey it sounds by no means am
i trying to disrespect fried chicken or
caviar i think it works tremendously the
person that's actually cooking is tony
kim he's executive chef of all the
noodle bars any time tony cooks it's a
treat we brine the chicken in a
buttermilk solution for a day buttermilk
helps tenderize it gives it flavor great
fried chicken is about getting fissures
as it fries doing this is about creating
irregularity in the batter we created a
dredge for it of flour spices and then
we fry it whole let it rest for at least
30 minutes because you don't want it
super hot trade all the sauces and the
garni scallion crepe white sauce chives
and creme fraiche we're pairing it with
what i believe is the best domestic
caviar by regales some of the most
beautiful sturgeon and we're also going
to pair it with some smoked trout the
salinity and oceanic grindiness of the
caviar is perfect for the white meat
present at table size show it to you and
then we're going to bring it back or
slice it that's actually a trickier
process you're sort of peeling the skin
and cutting at the same time assemble it
like you would with a peking duck this
is not something you should eat every
day if you guys are meeting your friends
in new york city and you haven't seen
them in a few years this is the kind of
meal that you'd want and if you break it
down amongst five to six people it's not
that bad as a friend of worth it would
you do the honor of dying with us today
this is going to be great this is one of
my favorite things to eat
that looks nice a lot of chinese new
year ducks eaten this way is this just
like a big chicken in the egg joke
chicken egg and caviar that's one of the
most classic culinary pairings this is
just a mature egg i'm gonna make you one
how about that
thank you i'm gonna let you do white
meat just to see this is creme fraiche
with scallions again this is something
that's a traditional garnish oh yeah
sturgeon from idaho cheers hello
sunshine hello
hello white clouds floating by
hello cooling summer breeze coming
whistling through the trees
[Music]
i hate how good this is those are the
two most awesome textures side by side
it's like one of the most complex things
i've eaten even though it's so simple
i'll make you one with the trout rub
it's very different hello positivity
surrounding everything i see hello happy
hello free hello and hello me
okay that is crazy going from the really
hot fried crisp and then having those
bubbles pop in your mouth afterwards
it's like going to the fair and then the
fireworks pop off all in your mouth it
reminds me of like a refrigerator raid
for some reason i didn't eat all this
awesome food we have a scallion pancake
we got some chicken oh and i got caviar
is it weird to mix the two i've actually
never done that you're gonna be making
history
pioneer
[Music]
not as good
you wanna do this real quick adam can i
make him one
[Music]
oh you're doing something that i like
the drumstick coated i actually wanted
to dip this in the caviar but i thought
that would be rude for you guys no no no
that's not rude at all this is like a
fever dream
oh
okay
it's all right i've never cursed on
camera on the show before
that bite was so good i didn't even talk
to you about that i wanted to see if
someone was going to do what you did and
eating that fried chicken that way yeah
and you sort of like passed the willy
wonka test
god damn it it's a tin a paddle whoa
it's cheaper but you can get way more of
it if we're gonna make fried chicken
caviar let's go all the way just dunk it
in and crust the whole thing where are
we
this is like an ice cream cone with
sprinkles on it cheers
i'm sorry i just can't not laugh at this
that's the whole point i'm in it to win
it man this is gonna ruin me i think you
know those weird people that bring their
own salad dressing to a restaurant yeah
i start coming to fried chicken
restaurants with like my own tin of
caviar i love mixing things that are
high low or things that aren't supposed
to traditionally go together when i'm
looking at this i'm inspired by france
china the american south so for me it's
genuinely not about the shock value at
all it's about always number one that's
delicious number two respecting the
cultures that you're taking it from yes
this is sort of perverse but if you
really look at it it's really sort of
like makes sense yeah and in a day i
don't care what you're putting together
if it tastes good in my mouth it's all
that matters
there you go sir
yeah
oh my god
like really get it in there crust it
crust this is like we're filming a rap
video or something
[Music]
[Laughter]
you simultaneously drooled while you
tried to take those last bite feels like
you're doing something wrong right all
right should i just say my winner you
know what yeah noodle bar
yeah i predicted you would say red
rooster i know i thought it was too the
single best bite of food today was the
first bite of the red rooster yard bird
but for this comparison kind of thing i
picked noodle bar people routinely spend
150 or more seeing their favorite
artists you could very easily make the
argument that going out to a dinner like
that is as powerful performance if you
will
let me break it down for you how it
actually should go sophia's is the og
she set the tone for fried chicken in
america but i thought red rooster was
gonna be all of our worth of winners
because red rooster is my worth of
winner today as it should be i mean it
was really good it really was the best
fried chicken i've ever had it was
magical adam who is your worth it winner
i know what you're going to say you're
going to choose the same one as him no
you're not no you're not
are you serious
noodle bar thank you for watching the
fried chicken episode worth it out i
love a mixture of plates very pleasing
that's something i aspire to have in my
own home but i think it takes a long
time maybe one really hard weekend of
antiquing i could get it together
i need some more bourbon oh yes